CHRIS.
>> Chris: MARK MEREDITH
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, DR. DEBORAH
BIRX, COORDINATOR OF THE
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE.
DOCTOR, WELCOME TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
>> Dr. Birx: THANK YOU.
>> Chris: WHERE ARE WE WITH
THE VIRUS?
ARE WE PAST THE PEAK?
ARE WE ON THE DOWNSLOPE NOW, AND
GIVEN THAT JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS PROJECTING
60,000 FATALITIES AND WE ARE
ALREADY UP TO 66,000, HOW MANY
MORE FATALITIES SHOULD WE EXPECT
IN THIS COUNTRY?
SPEECH AT, LET ME START WITH,
OUR PROJECTIONS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
BETWEEN 100,240,000 AMERICAN
LIVES LOST AND THAT’S WITH FULL
MEDICATION AND US LEARNING FROM
EACH OTHER OF HOW TO SOCIAL
DISTANCE.
EVERY SINGLE METRO AREA AND
EVERY SINGLE OUTBREAK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS DIFFERENT AND SO
WHEREAS NEW ORLEANS AND NOW
DETROIT AND SOME OF OUR OTHER
METROS SHOWING SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE, OTHERS ARE JUST
REACHING STEADY STATE.
WE ARE ENCOURAGED THAT THE
NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY METRO
AREAS ARE STARTING TO SEE A
DECLINE AFTER A LONG, FLAT CURVE
CURVE.
>> Chris: AS WE SAID, ABOUT
HALF THE STATES -- MORE THAN
HALF THE STATES HAVE STARTED IN
SOME WAY, SHAPE, OR FORM,
REOPENING.
BUT WE’VE CRUNCHED THE NUMBERS,
DOCTOR, AND NOT A SINGLE STATE
HAS MET THE WHITE HOUSE GATING
GUIDELINES OF TWO WEEKS OF
STEADY DECLINE IN NEW CASES.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
PATCHWORK REOPENING, AND WHY
LEAVE IT UP THE GOVERNORS?
WHY NOT SET A FIRM, IF NOT
BINDING, A FIRM NATIONAL POLICY
ON ONE STATES CAN REOPEN?
>> Dr. Birx: I THINK FEDERAL
GUIDELINES ARE A PRETTY FIRM
POLICY OF WHAT WE THINK IS
IMPORTANT FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
STANDPOINT.
WE ALSO MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR
STATES TO OPEN COUNTIES
INDEPENDENTLY OF THE ENTIRE
STATE, BECAUSE AGAIN, SOME OF
THESE OUTBREAKS ARE VERY LOCAL
AND HAVE TO BE STUDIED AND
UNDERSTOOD THAT WAY.
AND SO AS STATES REOPEN, WE
REALLY WANT THEM TO FOLLOW THE
GATING CRITERIA BUT WE ALSO MADE
IT VERY CLEAR TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DO TO PROTECT
YOURSELF.
YOU NEED TO CONTINUE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCE.
YOU NEED TO CONTINUE TO PRACTICE
SCRUPULOUS HAND WASHING.
YOU NEED TO KNOW WHERE YOUR
HANDS AND WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN
AND WHAT THEY HAVE TOUCHED AND
MAKE SURE YOU DON’T TOUCH HER
FACE AND I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTLY, IF YOU HAVE ANY
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS, THROUGH
PHASE ONE AND PHASE TWO GO OF
ANY REOPENING, WE HAVE ASKED YOU
TO CONTINUE TO SHELTER IN PLACE.
WE KNOW WHO’S A PARTICULAR RISK
FOR A VERY DIFFICULT COURSE WITH
THIS VIRUS AND WE CANNOT
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH HOW STRONGLY WE
FEEL IF YOU HAVE A COEXISTING
CONDITION TO CONTINUE TO SHELTER
IN PLACE.
>> Chris: BUT CLEARLY WHEN YOU
LEAVE IT UP TO INDIVIDUAL
GOVERNORS AND GOVERNORS ARE NOT
OBSERVING THE TWO WEEK DECLINE
BEFORE THEY OPEN, THAT SOUNDS A
VERY MIXED MESSAGE TO A LOT OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT APPEALING TO.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING THAT
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, YOUR
COLLEAGUE ON THE TASK FORCE,
SAID THIS WEEK.
HERE IT IS.
>> WOULD GIVE THE GOVERNORS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE VERY FLEXIBLE,
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE CORE
PRINCIPLES OF THE GUIDELINES.
YOU CAN’T JUST LEAP OVER THINGS
AND GET INTO A SITUATION WHERE
YOU ARE REALLY TEMPTING A
REBOUND.
>> Chris: DO YOU SHARE
DR. FAUCI’S GUIDELINES ABOUT
THIS PATCHWORK REOPENING THAT
SOME GOVERNORS, SOME STATES ARE
JUMPING THE GUIDELINES AND RISK
A REBOUND?
>> Dr. Birx: WE MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT THE GUIDELINES ARE
BASED ON VERY STRONG EVIDENCE
AND DATA AND THAT IS THE WAY
DR. FAUCI HAS ALSO DRIVEN.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL, EVERY EMPLOYER, AND
EVERY PERSON KNOWS HOW TO KEEP
THEMSELVES SAFE IN THIS
SITUATION.
WE’VE MADE IT CLEAR WITH THE
GATING CRITERIA AS WE PASSED
EVERY GOVERNOR, BECAUSE I KNOW
THEY’RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THEIR
STATE.
WE’VE ASKED EVERY GOVERNOR TO
POST ON THE WEBSITE AND ON A
DASHBOARD WHERE EXACTLY THEY ARE
IN THE GATING CRITERIA, BUT ALSO
TO MAKE ALL THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND TO
HAVE SITES -- SOPHISTICATED
SITES LIKE FLORIDA DOES THAT
MANY OTHER LIKE MASSACHUSETTS
DOES, SO PEOPLE CAN SEE WHERE
THE VIRUSES IN THEIR COMMUNITY,
BECAUSE AN EDUCATED COMMUNITY
CAN REALLY TAKE ACTION TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
>> Chris: WELL, LET’S TALK
ABOUT HOW EDUCATED SOME OF THE
COMMUNITIES ARE.
I’M GOING TO DO A LIGHTNING ROD,
QUICK QUESTIONS, QUICK ANSWERS,
ABOUT SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
THAT PEOPLE ARE ENGAGING IN
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
FIRST OF ALL, CALIFORNIA, WHERE
THIS PAST WEEK THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WERE MASSING ON BEACHES
IN VERY CLOSE QUARTERS.
SIMPLE QUESTION, IS THAT SAFE?
>> Dr. Birx: IF IT’S DONE WITH
SOCIAL DISTANCING, YES, IF IT’S
NOT DONE WITH SOCIAL DISTANCING,
NO.
>> Chris: WELL, I DON’T LOVE
YOU CAN SEE THE VIDEO, THERE WAS
NO SOCIAL DISTANCING, WHICH WAS
ONE OF THE REASONS THE GOVERNOR
SHOT THOSE BEACHES.
LET’S TALK ABOUT A DIFFERENT
ISSUE BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING A
LOT OF GOVERNORS OPEN UP THINGS
LIKE BEAUTY SALONS OR SPAS WERE
PEOPLE COME INTO VERY CLOSE
CONTACT.
IF YOU’RE GETTING A HAIRCUT, A
MASSAGE WITH EACH OTHER.
QUESTION, IF BOTH SIDES, BOTH
PARTIES, ARE WEARING MASKS, IS
THAT SAFE?
>> Dr. Birx: IT’S SAFER, BUT
WE’VE MADE IT CLEAR THAT THAT IS
NOT A GOOD PHASE ONE ACTIVITY
AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
MADE THAT CLEAR WHEN HE
DISCUSSED THE CASE IN GEORGIA.
>> Chris: WELL, YOU KNOW
THAT’S HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
LET ME ASK ABOUT ONE MORE
ACTIVITY.
BIG CROWDS OF PROTESTERS THAT
WENT INTO THE MICHIGAN STATE
CAPITAL WITHOUT MASKS, MASSING
TOGETHER IN CLOSE QUARTERS.
I’M NOT ASKING YOU ABOUT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
PROTEST, THAT OF COURSE THEY
HAVE.
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT,
IS THAT SAFE?
>> Dr. Birx: IT’S
DEVASTATINGLY WORRISOME TO ME
PERSONALLY BECAUSE IF THEY GO
HOME AND INFECTS THE GRANDMOTHER
OR THE GRANDFATHER WHO HAS A
COMORBID CONDITION AND THEY HAVE
A SERIOUS OR AN UNFORTUNATE
OUTCOME, THEY WILL FEEL GUILTY
FOR THE REST OF OUR LIVES.
SO WE NEED TO PROTECT EACH OTHER
AT THE SAME TIME WHERE VOICING
OUR DISCONTENT.
>> Chris: LET’S TALK ABOUT
REMDESIVIR, THE FDA GAVE
EMERGENCY APPROVAL TO USE OF
THIS DRUG TO HELP PEOPLE HAVE
THE VIRUS.
IS IT A SILVER BULLET IN TERMS
OF REDUCING LETHALITY, KEEPING
PEOPLE FROM DYING AND ALSO IN
TERMS OF SIDE EFFECTS.
>> Dr. Birx: WELL FIRST, IT’S
ONLY HALF THE DATA AND THE THE D
SAFE TO MODERN BOARD AND
INDEPENDENT GROUPS THOUGHT THAT
THE IMPROVEMENT WAS COMPELLING
ENOUGH AND SIGNIFICANTLY ENOUGH
TO ACTUALLY SAY THAT THEY
COULDN’T CONTINUE THE TRIAL AS
IT WAS IN THE PLACEBO ARM HAD TO
RECEIVE THE EFFECTIVE DRUG.
SO IT’S A FIRST STEP FORWARD.
IN PARALLEL, WE HAVE A WHOLE
SERIES OF THERAPEUTICS INCLUDING
PLASMA AND ALSO MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES BEING WORKED THROUGH.
WE ARE CONCENTRATING ON VACCINES
AS WELL AS THERAPEUTIC BRIDGES
TO ENSURE THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND DO WELL WITH THIS
VIRUS EVENTUALLY.
WE REALLY WANT TO ENSURE THE
SPELL THERAPEUTIC AVAILABLE AND
VACCINES AVAILABLE RAPIDLY.
>> Chris: THEN THERE’S
OPERATION WARP SPEED, WHICH IS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION’S
EFFORT TO TRY TO DEVELOP A
VACCINE BY NEXT JANUARY.
YOU AND DR. FAUCI HAVE TALKED
SORT OF THE RULE OF THUMB IS 12
MONTHS TO 18 MONTHS, THAT WOULD
BE CONSIDERABLY SHORTER THAN
THAT TIMETABLE.
NEXT JANUARY, IS THAT REALISTIC?
SPEAK OF THE WAY THAT IT’S
POSSIBLE IS IF YOU BRING FORWARD
FIVE OR SIX DIFFERENT CLASSES OF
CANDIDATES, WHICH THE OPERATION
WARP SPEED HAS DONE.
AND SO IT’S NOT RELYING ON A
SINGLE VACCINE PLATFORM.
IT’S RELYING ON SEVERAL
DIFFERENT CANDIDATES THAT ARE
MADE DIFFERENTLY HAD ASKED
DIFFERENTLY AND THEN IT’S ABOUT
DOING COMPRESSED PHASE ONE,
PHASE TWO, PHASE THREE TRIALS IN
AN OVERLAPPING WAY, MOVING
FORWARD WHEN YOU HAVE A GOOD
SAFETY -- NOT WITH THE LEVEL OF
PAUSES THAT ARE OFTEN PRESENT IN
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT, AND SO ON
PAPER IT’S POSSIBLE.
IT’S WHETHER WE CAN EXECUTE AND
EXECUTE AROUND THE GLOBE BECAUSE
YOU ALSO, FOR PHASE THREE, HAVE
TO HAVE ACTIVE VIRAL
TRANSMISSION IN THE COMMUNITY IN
ORDER TO STUDY ITS EFFICACY.
>> Chris: FINALLY, DOCTOR,
I’VE GOT ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT,
THERE IS A NEW REPORT OUT OF
AUSTRALIA THIS WEEKEND THAT FIVE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES, INCLUDING
THE U.S., HAVE PUT TOGETHER A
DOSSIER THAT INDICATES THAT THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT IN THE EARLY
STAGES EITHER HEAD OR COVERED UP
THE FACT OF THE CORONAVIRUS AND
ITS SPREAD IN JAPAN.
I’M NOT GOING TO ASK YOU TO
COMMENT IN ANY WAY ON
INTELLIGENCE, BUT FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH STANDPOINT, THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY FROM CHINA IN THE
EARLY DAYS, IN JANUARY,
FEBRUARY, EVEN INTO MARCH, DID
THAT SLOWED ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> Dr. Birx: WHEREVER THAT
FIRST JUMP OCCURS, WHETHER IT’S
FROM ANIMAL TO HUMAN OR LAB TO
HUMAN, IT DOESN’T REALLY MATTER,
WHOEVER, WHEREVER THAT HAPPENS,
YOU HAVE TO OVER COMMUNICATE,
BECAUSE THAT’S WHEN YOU GET THE
FIRST INSTANCE OF HOW
TRANSMITTABLE THIS VIRUSES.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT IT’S
PARTICULARLY SUSCEPTIBLE TO?
THAT DIDN’T HAPPEN AND IT DIDN’T
HAPPEN UNTIL LATE AND YOU KNOW
IT DIDN’T HAPPEN UNTIL
MID-JANUARY THEY EVEN TALKED
ABOUT HUMAN TO HUMAN
TRANSMISSION.
AND THAT REALLY -- AND WHEN YOU
SEE HOW MANY COUNTRIES NOW ARE
INFECTED, THAT DID SPEND THE
VIRUS ACROSS THE GLOBE.
>> Chris: DR. BIRX, THANK YOU,